this video will teach you how to inject
your insulin using an
insulin pen
please watch the entire video before
injecting your insulin
your healthcare provider may recommend
that you inject insulin using an insulin
pen
to help you control your blood sugar
level
most pens come pre-filled with insulin
and are disposable
when the insulin runs out you can throw
the pen away
some pens are reusable and come with an
insulin cartridge that you load into the
pen
before using it injecting insulin with
an insulin pen
involves choosing an injection site
preparing and priming your pen and then
injecting the insulin into your body
your healthcare provider will tell you
what type of insulin you need
as well as when and how much you need to
inject
you will need alcohol wipes your insulin
pen
a new needle for each injection
and a sharps disposal container
a disposable pre-filled insulin pen has
the following
parts a pen cap
an insulin reservoir
a dosage indicator
a dosage dial and an injection button
insulin pen needles have a protective
pull tab
and an outer and inner needle cap
be sure to follow the instructions that
came with your insulin pen
selecting the injection site
before injecting your insulin select the
injection site on your body
the areas for insulin injection include
the abdomen or belly
the thighs upper arms
and the buttocks when selecting the
injection site
be sure you use a different spot each
time you give yourself an injection
leave at least one inch away from the
last injection spot
inject your insulin at least two inches
from your belly button
and choose a spot one inch or farther
away from any scar
or mole
preparing the insulin pen
step 1 wash your hands with soap and
water and then dry them
step 2 remove the cap from your insulin
pen
step 3 if your insulin needs to be mixed
gently roll the pen between your hands
then turn your pen up and down 10 times
do not shake your pen because it may
cause bubbles to form in your insulin
before injecting yourself check the
insulin in your pen to make sure
it is the type of insulin your doctor
prescribed for you
it is not past the expiration date it is
not discolored
and the insulin is free of clumps
step 4 use an alcohol wipe to clean the
end of the pen
where the needle attaches
step 5 remove the pull tab from the
needle
be sure to use a new needle each time
you inject insulin
step 6 with the outer and inner needle
cap still
in place attach the needle to your pen
according to the instructions
remove both the outer and inner needle
caps
do not touch the needle or allow it to
touch any surface
and do not use the needle if it is bent
a bent needle can block or prevent the
insulin from coming out
priming the insulin pen
priming the insulin pen replaces the air
in the needle with insulin
and removes any clogs or blockages this
ensures that you receive
all of the insulin you intend to inject
step one turn the dosage dial until you
see two units displayed in the dosage
indicator
step two hold the pen with the needle
pointing up
gently tap the end of the pen near the
needle two or three times
step three press the injection button
all the way in
until a drop of insulin appears on the
tip of the needle
you may need to repeat steps one through
three before seeing insulin appear on
the tip of the needle
if you need to set your pen down make
sure the needle does not touch
anything
injecting the insulin step 1
turn the dosage dial to the number of
insulin units you need to inject
step 2 clean your injection site with an
alcohol wipe
use a circular motion to clean a spot
about two inches wide
step three if you replace your pen's
inner needle cap
remove it now
step four pinch a two inch fold of skin
in the cleaned injection spot
step 5 quickly insert the pen's needle
straight into your skin
at a 90 degree angle make sure the whole
needle enters your skin step 6
push the pen's injection button all the
way down to inject the insulin into the
fat tissue beneath your skin
slowly count to 10 before removing the
needle to make sure you injected all of
the insulin
step 7 pull the needle straight out to
remove it
step 8 carefully put the outer cap back
onto the needle
and then turn the capped needle to
remove it from the pen
make sure you remove the needle after
each injection
never store your insulin pen with a
needle attached
step 9 throw away the needle into your
sharp's disposal container
never throw your needles directly into
the trash
contact your health care provider if you
have questions about injecting your
insulin or if your blood sugar level
stays above or below
your target range